[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا الاسبوع يسمى باسبوع التساوي وهو
الاسبوع الذي يتساوى في طول الليل مع
النهار فالنهار 12 ساعه والليل 12 ساعه
وفي نهايه هذا الاسبوع يبدا النهار يزيد
على حساب الليل لمده ثلاثه شهور تقريبا
رمضان وشوال وذا القعده ومع دخول شهر ذي
الحجه نعيش اطول نهر واقصر ليالي السنه
فمروره الشمس على خط الاستواء يعني تساوي
الليل مع النهار وتعامدها على مدار الجدي
يعني اطول ليله بالسنه وتعامدها على مدار
السرطان يعني اطول يوم بالسنه وهو اليوم
الذي يبدا قلب الارض يشعشع بالحراره قلبي
سمح يا حبيبي من مودكم خلى اللي كبروا
راسك يسرونك من اول احبك ومفرح بجيكم
واليوم عارف اللي عندي
يطرونك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والشمس تنطلق في رحله سنويه على شكل بندول
من مدار الجدي الى مدار السرطان مرورا على
خط الاستواء فتمر على خط الاستواء مرتين
بسنه بشكل سريع يا سرعها سرعاه دورات
الايام العام كله شهر واليوم ساعه اعمارنا
في نقص عام بعد عام وتزيدنا سوادا الليالي
بشاعه
[موسيقى]